terminal condition there is no
medication
there's really not a lot that we can do
for you
but there will be palliative care when
the time comes
I'm 33 wow
[Music]
hello hello I'm Kyle hi Jonathan lovely
to meet you too how are you doing all
right where have you come from today
I've come from Leeds so I live in Leeds
obviously not born there Scouts sport
what about you oh I'm easy London London
South London Hill
so yeah I'm I live in Leeds I went there
for uni and then just never left and I
am a drag performer as well all right
yeah so I do drag and then I work in
admin just you know pays the bills and
then I'm doing a lot of the advocacy on
the sides trying to turn that into more
of a career so yeah that's that's me
really
um and I know obviously a lot about you
do a lot of activism I've seen a lot of
it before yeah but I mean I I do but
it's extraordinary kind of sort of I
feel like I'm only just starting yeah
and yeah I've been living with this
virus for
now for 40 years yeah which is just
insane it seems crazy I was diagnosed
when I was 20.
so I was at Uni in Leeds
and
it was obviously still really hard but I
think it's just like being part of the
generation that kind of grew up with a
lot more education on it still not
enough but you know I was aware of it
and but you grew up with Section 28. I
did but so so homosexuality could not be
talked about exactly I grew up in a
environment where yeah we're just
learning about the heterosexual
counterpart so obviously we know that
HIV is not strictly a queer issue and
that anyone can contract it but that's
not what it was viewed as at the time
and for a lot of people still to this
day so I'm growing up no one Whispers of
this HIV thing the gay people can get
all the while thinking but I think I
might be gay so for me it was limited
knowledge and a lot of imagination
which can breed quite a
negative outlook on it where you think
oh God does that mean I'm gonna get that
is that like the standard so my actual
education on it was limited and lucky
for me I had people steer me in the
right direction so that when the time
came that I was diagnosed
it wasn't a complete shock and I'd done
my own research and I knew that the
facts so I think you know there's a
privilege there of no one no one a lot
more than your generation would have but
also at the same time you mentioned
section 28 teachers weren't saying
anything teachers weren't telling me
like but they could if you yeah I know
it's not their fault no no but you know
that was the the you know the the
absolute sort of wickedness of of
Margaret that yeah because to to to do
that and particularly do that because
you know this was was when HIV was
already around it wasn't called HIV but
it was already around so to actually
make sure that that that young
lesbian and gay people particularly gay
people did not have sexual education
that talked about yeah you know the the
both the dangers but also the the the
the possibilities yeah I think was I
think criminal for sure it's Erasure
isn't it so it's really interesting the
kind of the way things changed and and
shifted but I remember sort of
basically what had happened to me that
that every single lymph node in my body
had erupted I made an appointment to go
and see my uh my GP and I remember as I
walked in the room she got up and she
said shake my hand and as I shook her
hand she felt the lymph node in the
crook of my elbow and I went ow what did
you do that for she said that's the
sailor's handshake whenever the sailors
went into Port they would shape the
hands of the women or the men that they
were going with and if that lymph node
was up it was a sign of syphilis and
they wouldn't go with them so she said
have you had a checkup syphilis recently
so I said no I've had syphilis but no I
haven't so she said I suggest that that
you go and I used to go to James Pringle
house which was part of the Middlesex
Hospital so that was the
special Clinic I was going to say clap
Clinic the special Clinic I used to go
to and um so I went and I presented
myself and they were all over me
so I was there literally for for two
days waiting for for the results to come
when they came they said
you have a virus
um which
is causing you persistent
lymphadenopathy it's a terminal
condition there is no medication
there's really not a lot that we can do
for you
but there will be palliative care when
the time comes
I'm 33 wow do I want to hear about
palliative care I mean I was just winded
and then they said you can go home was
that called HIV or no they still could
they still didn't understand what that
was it wasn't didn't have a name so did
you have a moment where the military
said that you knew I know what this is
no no well you completely I don't know
anything about it before that at that
point I've sort of you know I wasn't
making any kind of connections yeah to
it
um at that point
I mean and it really wasn't until a lot
later because in 1986
finally got her name which was called
the virus was was called
htl V3 which was human
lymphadenopathy T Cell virus I mean
mouthful oh RS3
and so they came to some agreement that
they decided that they would call it HIV
which was human
immunodeficiency virus so basically
they call it what it does yeah what it
is but that wasn't until 1988.
well my story was a little bit
um different in the sense that I was
very sexually active at Uni you know I'm
like 20 okay living my best life I've
just moved City so I was
you know enjoying all that leads had to
offer and I was always very safe so
again like when my parents like as
embarrassing as it was when I went to
UNI my mum bought me condoms you know
very that story my mum and dad were
great for being like always use
protection even if it was uncomfortable
to talk about it so out of many partners
it was like two that I had had a unsafe
interaction with so I hadn't even given
it any thought which looking back was
kind of irresponsible but I went with my
best friend so she could get an STI
check because she had had an interaction
and then she had like a rash so she was
like I just want to check it's not
anything yeah will you come with me for
moral support so of course I went with
her so I was with her and then I think
the woman said something like do you
want to be tested as well it's free you
may as well so I was like okay I'll just
get one done thinking it would surely
all come back negative because and then
I got the text giving me the all clear
for chlamydia era so basically the urine
test yeah came back with nothing yeah
and then I got a phone call and she
asked me to come in for more Bloods
and as I said like I'm quite like
I was quite in the know about it at this
point so I was like does this mean I
have HIV you know level with me here on
the phone you actually answer on the
phone yeah right yeah I'm a very um
confident person but that's pretty and I
just was like just just tell me if I've
got it yeah yeah because that's where my
mind obviously went straight away right
um and she was like we can't confirm
that we just need to get you in for more
blood you know
she was doing her job so I didn't resent
her for it but I was like I always say
to people that that was my diagnosis
that's when I cried that's when I was
like my life's over when I actually then
went in for more Bloods and did the
tests and waited for the line to come
off
then I was really calm yeah I mean
the emotions in in terms of receiving a
diagnosis I mean I was winded I mean
it's the the only word to to describe it
because you know and it it wasn't shock
and in a way it wasn't fear I think I I
can't describe it was it was literally
just kind of
that
just the air is knocked out of you and
and
I remember you know leaving the hospital
kind of confused not really kind of
hadn't I don't suppose I'd taken it
quite taken it in taken it on board what
they had said
um the idea of palliative care just
seems
a nonsense yeah because of of being 33
so
um
and going back to to to my flat in the
East End I was living in this
lovely Peabody flat
um
but I was living on my own so I wasn't
sort of with people
and just closing the door
and just having this absolute sort of
collapse yeah that my life was over that
this was it
and I didn't get in touch with people
um
I didn't speak to anybody I didn't reach
out I just completely kind of
collapse sort of in on myself
um
I just had this growing internal
concerns around it where I was like
it's really just trying to wrap my head
around what it meant to have it then for
the rest of my life
and I remember I missed a Hospital
appointment purely by like
I just didn't make a you know happens to
all of us but then because I missed
there
it gave me this like unlocked and new
anxiety where I didn't want to go yeah
where I was like
it probably it probably got to over a
year where I just wasn't going to the
doctors about it and I was ignoring it
because I hadn't come to terms with
having it yet I guess and then it then
transformed into a fear of I'm gonna go
back and they're going to be like it's
AIDS now like you've lasted too long
essentially I eventually
um had like a meltdown to a really
really good friend of mine Lucy and was
like look I've been
basically Shack in my medical
responsibilities here and ignoring the
help and I'm scared and I had a very
vulnerable moment with her and she was
like
talking through it and was like make an
appointment right now and I'm gonna frog
March you there whenever it is I'm not
gonna let you miss her and she you know
encouraged me and helped me and made me
go to it and of course the doctor was
like
hi welcome back to start you on meds and
it was so casual and I was like I spoke
with my younger brother
my younger brother who went to medical
school to be a doctor was now living in
in London I was able to tell him
what my diagnosis was by that time it
now had a name so you know where we're
going on it wasn't really early
um and he I knew that that I could tell
him and then when I got ill
he would be able to tell my parents
because I just felt I can't
tell my parents I cannot put them
through
this whole I'd put them through the fact
of of coming out as yeah
gay
I thought that was enough
slightly similar thing in the terms of
like I put off telling my parents for a
long time it's amazing but it's just
interesting when you say that it's all
like there was a bit of a mirror of like
how I felt but in a completely different
context of course but it is fascinating
that same this shared experience that a
lot of us probably have yeah just not
wanting to disappoint people
so did you share with them or was it
your brother I I never shared with uh
with uh my family and I mean I remember
that that uh
seeing my mother to my mother had had
her a heart attack and
I'd gone to see her in Coventry Hospital
and just there was a path for me that I
was so relieved
that
I was never going to have to tell her
yeah
so have you lost anyone because of HIV
um
I'll go first because it's easier for me
to answer I I've been very very
fortunate to not have
um
you know I've I know my history you know
I know about a lot of the more famous
cases you know the stuff that
is our responsibility as HIV positive
people to be in the know about but on a
personal level you know I'm very lucky
but I haven't or
imagine things are probably very
different for you no
and yeah I mean
I mean very early on
um
I'm sorry
it's it
is difficult to talk about of course
basically
um
but yeah I mean oh God
I think that
the thing that was most difficult around
it was
the fact that the Youth of of of people
um
because I was 33 when I was diagnosed
and
well like you were 20 and that seemed to
be the the that the age that graduated
the majority of people
who were diagnosed and died
because there was no medication and and
what have you
um
so yeah it's it's it's
and it's still
it's difficult yeah
um
you feel it feels
like
people are like cheated of life doesn't
it feels you think about all of the
amazing like
artists and creators and yeah talent and
love love that that is is lost it just
feels unjust I think that's what it gets
to us so much I think so I think so
because death is easier to rationalize
when you die peacefully in your sleep
because you're old you know what I mean
yeah and that you've that you've
had a had a love you know I've had a
life I've had an amazing life so when I
go you know that'll be fine but but
the difference that the medication has
made is just yeah phenomenal it's it's
it's really incredible
it's like
you know it's just a travesty though
yeah we have to lose so many people
before
um
but I really like I really respect you
for sitting there and talking about it
like this because it's not easy at all
and like people like you to me are
pioneers and you know
survivors and I just I think it's
incredible
and I know it's really emotional but
like I thank you for being so open about
it and
it means a lot to people like me thank
you and
um
oh no that wasn't easy to do
ball you're still here and that's yeah
well I mean I have I'm so grateful for
her well thank you I mean I I just feel
so extraordinarily fortunate yeah
to me
the most important thing for anybody
newly diagnosed
is actually to make friends with your
virus that is good advice because you
know
the virus is going to be with you
forever
so you might as well just befriend it
then
everything else
will bit by bit into place and it is you
know we are so as you say so fortunate
that that
we live in the country whereby
you know we have this medication like
you say everything is just way more
accessible now sure so yeah by 2030 we
should be eradicating new cases and we
won there's no reason why we shouldn't
you know especially like if we keep
talking about it because the the
unfortunate thing is people just don't
know about these things well they don't
so I think the general advice to anyone
either living with it or knowing someone
living with it is to not be ignorant to
the stuff that is available to you
because there's plenty of information
getting tested is easier than it's ever
been getting medication is easier than
it's ever been and also fans and support
for the actual journey is easier than
it's ever been so I think we as people
do have a tendency to
be a bit ignorant naturally and to just
go with what we know but it's about like
shaking off what stigma's been instilled
in you over the years
um being receptive to the cold hard
facts that we have from science medicine
and then also having that emotional
availability to hear the stories of
people that do live with it because
there are many and they are different
and they are hard to hear sometimes but
the issue is that HIV is such a loaded
word and if we take the power away from
that word and if we
stop thinking oh this is going to be
really emotional this is harrowing like
yeah yeah it can be emotional it can be
ugly but like
isn't everything at times you know what
I mean so it's approaching HIV as a
topic
without thinking of it as something
that's scary or heavy I started
volunteering for a charity called
Skyline in Leeds who are a support group
for people in HIV that kind of forced me
to learn even more and like I feel like
there's such a rich tapestry to like
look back on and I feel like we our way
to ourselves and to also the over 40
million people we've lost the HIV to
know our history and to you know
not everyone has to like be an advocate
in the way that we are and everyone has
to go there be in public about
everything younger people living with
HIV older people who survived and are
still living with HIV we have to just be
so thankful for how far it's come but I
think also sort of you know what's
important is that that this message has
got out yeah because
there are
there's not enough even today there is
not enough that is spoken about it so
that people really do not understand the
fact that we do have effective
medication that is you know anybody can
access it I mean that that that's what
is so extraordinary that that still if
you present with HIV whoever you are
yeah you know whether you're a refugee
whether you're a migrant what have you
you access the medication and yeah and
that's fantastic do you mind like
shaking hands for the last time
pleasure
like you
thank you you're very much for people
like you oh it's been a pleasure so I
was taken into a darkened room no
windows
um sat in a chair a wooden chair uh this
arm was strapped with leather straps to
the chair
I had electrodes which they had soaked
in salt water
placed on my arms stuck on my arm